no I think there's been a great deal of
hyperbole the regulations that the
Lord's considered on Monday were
required to be laid before the Lord's as
well as the Commons under the tax
credits act 2002 and the Lord's
considered them they came to a view
which the government didn't like that
much
well certainly the House of Commons
hasn't acted against I would say
constitutional law it may have had a
surprising in the view of the government
a surprising attitude to some of the
conventions governing relations between
the two houses but I don't think it's
the end of the world in any way
well I think the government will need to
consider the events of Monday and the
transfer has indicated that he's going
to soften his proposals and perhaps
introduce transitional arrangements if
that happens then I think that will meet
an ass wage a lot of public concern
concern in the Lord's but also and
pretty highly relevant lis concern
amongst his own conservative
backbenchers in the Commons
statutory instrument is something which
can be done by ministers under pars
given to them by the parent Act one
I think regrettable trend in the use of
statutory instruments is to put in them
major issues of policy and principle
which really ought to be on the face of
a bill and so subject to the scrutiny
that a bill gets and not left to
subsequent regulations by statutory
instruments
no because the government has behaved
entirely according to the law
regulations have been made as foreseen
in the parent Act and they've been laid
before both houses so know the
government has behaved entirely properly
from that point of view
I think that would be a huge
overreaction and I think the government
would get a lot more criticism than that
they would get long-term political
advantage I think tempers and emotions
have been running high over the last few
days and I think the most sensible thing
just to give a little time for things to
settle down then people will see it in
proportion